this is super interesting um many of you
know about republican congressman kevin
mccarthy now kevin mccarthy is a guy who
back around the trump riots was speaking
regularly
not only with donald trump but with
other people in that circle and cnn has
unearthed audio of kevin mccarthy saying
i spoke to trump
and trump admitted he has some
responsibility for the riots to me now
why is this relevant it's relevant
because for the last year plus now year
and two weeks almost to the day
donald trump and people around him have
been
denying that trump had anything to do
with what ultimately took place
and or saying
it was peaceful
and or saying the violence was antifa so
all of those different things conflict
some of them cancel each other out it
doesn't matter the point is they've gone
out of their way to say
trump there's no responsibility here for
trump whatsoever for what happened on
january 6th and yet and yet
cnn unearths audio of kevin mccarthy
saying trump admitted responsibility for
the riot
cnn's k file resurfaced the top house
republicans comments to a california
radio station days after the january 6th
insurrection
um let's just listen to the audio take a
listen to exactly what kevin mccarthy
said i say he has responsibility he told
me personally that he does have some
responsibility i think a lot of people
do but what i proposed which i think
history will say i'm right because it's
the right thing to do i believe
have a bipartisan commission and get all
your facts
actually work through the grand jury to
find out at the end instead of
pre-determining whether someone's guilty
or not pretty wow i mean it's not only a
good idea have a special committee do a
special investigation well it's
happening now and republicans are
essentially completely opposed to it but
kevin mccarthy clearly says
i believe trump has some responsibility
and trump admitted to me that he has
some responsibility this has been
completely buried
now kevin mccarthy was more recently
asked about it he forgot guys he doesn't
remember kevin mccarthy says he doesn't
remember the phone call where trump
admitted some responsibility days after
january 6th
house minority leader kevin mccarthy
told other republicans in a phone call
that trump claimed some responsibility
for the capitol riot according to cnn
but during a news conference thursday
mccarthy said he couldn't recall the
phone call uh here was kevin mccarthy
asked about it check this out did you
tell house republicans on a january 11
phone call that president trump told you
he agreed that he bore some
responsibility for january 6 as chairman
thompson's letter indicates
i'm not sure what call you're talking
about
knocked up here and then he goes on to a
different reporter now notice the very
specific language i don't know what call
you were talking about that's a very
different answer than i have never said
nor believed
trump admitted responsibility nor is
responsible so if someone said to me
did you say that and i go i don't know
what phone call you're talking about
it's not a denial
right sort of like if someone says hey
did you um
did did you call and threaten
to uh steal pizza from a pizza hut
and i go i don't know what phone call
you're referring to that's a very
different answer than i've never called
pizza hut and threatened to steal pizza
these are two very very different
reactions and kevin mccarthy
listen if you have to guess what the
truth is the truth is at the time it
wasn't yet clear that for a year trump
and the people around him would deny
that he had anything to do with the riot
so kevin mccarthy said it
uh in early january mid-january of 2021
and meant it and it was true
and now in retrospect it would look very
very bad
for mccarthy to say this last year of
trump and everybody around him
pretending like he had nothing to do
with it and there's nothing to see here
well a year ago trump admitted to me
that he had some responsibility that
would look very very bad for trump and
it would probably put kevin mccarthy in
the doghouse so i believe that trump did
say it i believe mccarthy uh did report
it at the time
and now he's just lying and it's such a
technical and specific answer i don't
know what phone call you are referring
to
is a world away
from i've never said it because trump
never said it to me and i don't believe
that he bears any responsibility those
are dramatically different things
a great way to support the david pakman
show is by supporting our sponsors today
one of our sponsors is sheath underwear
the only men's underwear that once and
for all ends the sticking
and the chafing and the readjusting that
traditional underwear causes sheath
creates ergonomic boxer briefs designed
to keep everything separate dry cool and
comfortable if you've only worn
traditional underwear give sheath a try
it's a level of comfort you probably
didn't even know is possible because it
prevents skin on skin contact this is
the future of underwear stop wearing
uncomfortable underwear that mashes and
constricts
wear sheath to keep yourself comfortable
and sweat free the amazing reviews
online speak for themselves people love
sheath underwear it's excellent and
sheath is giving my audience
20 off when you go to sheath
underwear.com pacman and use the code
pacman the link is down below